This UCSD-TV program is presented by University
of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow us on Facebook
and Twitter to keep up with the latest programs.
[Music]
00:52
Good evening, everybody.
Uh, welcome to the Joan B. Kroc School of
Peace Studies.
Uh, in this school, uh, we believe that you
don't have very much peace, and it's not very
sustainable without justice, and we don't
think you have much justice without peace.
So we think the two go together inext--inextricably.
We also believe that studies ought to be combined
with practice, and so our Institute for Peace
& Justice and our Trans-Border Institute are
very involved in the practice, in various
places around the world, of peace and justice
issues.
We also believe that peace and justice shouldn't
be an abstraction.
It should be a challenge of public policy.
So we are developing the school as the first
school of public policy devoted to the questions
of peace and justice.
Now... [applause] Uh, this is going to be
an inspiring evening.
First because I'm going to leave the podium
very shortly, [laughter] uh, and secondly
in Leymah we have someone who has
inspired people throughout the world and we've
already had the benefit of her twice today
and we appreciate her patience to have her
for a third time.
Now I've only been dean of this school for
a little over six months, but you learn a
few things.
One of the things you learn very quickly is,
whenever possible, delegate.
And so tonight I am very pleased to delegate,
uh, to Dee Akers, who is known as the woman
peacemaker, uh [applause] and as someone who's
known, uh, Leymah for many years, in fact
welcomed her here five years ago.
Uh, so Dee is going to engage in a conversation,
uh, with Leymah.
And with that let me exit the stage and thank
you all very much for coming.
We appreciate having you.
Thank you.
[applause]
Well, good evening and let me add my welcome
to our dean's.
And thank you for joining us here at the Kroc
School of Peace Studies at the University
of San Diego, for the Joan B. Kroc Institute
for Peace & Justice's Distinguished Lecture,
"Transforming Conflict through Nonviolent
Coalitions," with a truly brave and, above
all, transparent and honest woman.
Um, it's my privilege and pleasure to share
an evening with the 2011 Nobel Peace Laureate,
Leymah Gbowee, and you, uh, because it takes
all of us, as she often points out.
And our evening is designed to let us step
into her world briefly and the revelations
there.
This Liberian mom of six, domestic violence
survivor, peace activist, social worker, women's
rights advocate who speaks truth to power,
who founded a number of organizations including
most recently the Gbowee Peace Foundation
Africa, and along the way got the Nobel Peace
Prize — all before she was 40 years old.
[applause] A slightly longer bio is in your
program.
And the book "Mighty Be Our Powers," uh, which
tells intimately her story is available out
in the rotunda, um and it's really her story
on how this came to pass, but there's also
some people that would love for you to, uh,
or be thrilled, if you went back and found
the film, "Pray the Devil Back to Hell."
Netflix would be happy if you'd rent it and,
uh, Abigail Disney would be glad if you bought
it.
Um, and we're actually really happy to see
how... in that film... how this happened with
the diverse community.
And those of you who have met her here before
five years ago saw the film when she joined
us for a conference that we did called "Crafting
Human Security in an Insecure World."
Um, there's so much to talk about, but we
want you to have time to do it.
I'm going to ask just a few questions and
we'll have a little bit of discussion up here.
But I want you to know that we were encouraged
and engaged on the promise that she made and
was living when she came here before.
And, uh, it appears, however, that I have
to say something that I really believe that
her nonviolent transformation activities are
sometimes not a passive, quiet, nonviolent,
[laughter] uh, style but very vocal, direct
and shall we say risky, uh, in which way she,
uh, leads, uh, the way to peace in Liberia
and elsewhere now around the world.
So, welcome, Leymah.
Thank you, Dee.
Thank you so much.
[applause] Well, one thing...we'll start a
little towards the beginning, not the very
beginning, we only have an hour, um, when
you were 17 years old the Liberian civil war
had just started.
And you, uh, said that you turned from being
a child into an adult in a matter of hours.
Um, can you give us a feeling for what it
was like, what that—that moment was like,
that journey was like from then on and what
changed?
Alright.
Thank you and thank you all for coming.
It's truly an honor to be back here, uh, five
years later.
I do then, since 2008, I now have a 3-year-old
going on 40, so since I left I've been really
busy.
[laughter] But, um, I grew up in a very sheltered,
not rich community, but very sheltered.
Um, where we grew up was the typical, um,
example of "ubuntu" — you know—you are
because I am; we all exist because of the
other.
Liberia has 16 tribes.
The community we grew up in, maybe 10 of those
tribes lived there.
Everyone practiced their culture, but we were
children of the community.
So at 5 o'clock, if you went to the next neighbor's
house, you took your bath there and put on
someone else's clothes, and they took you
home sleeping.
We would stand on our porch and shout, "What
did you cook today?"
And someone would say, "We cooked rice with
cassava leaves and rice with...Can we share?"
So those were the kinds of things that we
did.
And when lights went off, we sang and danced
our cultural, sang different traditional songs.
Everyone came out so all of the parents were
sitting on their porch.
There was that feeling of you're sheltered.
And then we'd go to town to the very plush
high schools, but also sheltered because all
of the kids in those schools' parents...or
in our school...parents knew each other.
We were still children at 17.
You could go to your dad and say, "I need
this."
Your mom.
There was guidance.
And then we wake up and we were hearing all
these stories about war.
And we wake up one morning, my mother is gone,
my father is gone, and I'm waiting for a few
hours to go to school.
And then there's shooting.
Real loud shooting.
This old man says, "I—I know this sound.
The rebels have come."
And my sister's three kids are at home, and
my two younger siblings are there.
And I'm the only child of my parents at home
at that moment.
And my niece is running to the door and one
of our relatives is coming with another child
and she takes her out of the way.
Standing and observing that interaction at
that moment, it was like, "You have to take
charge."
So I took all of those kids in, and that night
people were coming and asking me, "What are
we eating?"
This is a question I ask people, you know,
and then my aunt was saying to me, "You have
to take control of your parent's bedroom."
By morning we had over 50 people internally
displaced in our home.
I had to be saying, "Let's cook this, let's
do this, let's do that."
So you wake up at 8 in the morning and you're
a 17-year-old.
And by 10 p.m. you're 20-something or 30-something
because you have the burden and the responsibility
of a whole group of people on your shoulder.
And people are already beginning to tell you,
"Look around and find those important documents
of your parents to keep.
Do this, do that."
Those are not things that ordinary 17-year-olds
think about.
But in a matter of weeks I mastered all of
it.
One thing that you had with your family, um,
and in your community, uh, was a sense of
faith.
You became a person or you were a person of
But it seems that you came to know and live
your convictions so much more than simply
being church dogma.
Um, in today's world, institutionalized religions
can seem separate from people and you went
through, uh, the way they live.
But in your transition and during those times,
from that point on, what was it like for you,
how did you go beyond or include your sense
of faith?
In who you became.
Well, when you live in a world where you see
a lot of injustice happening and people who
profess to be true believers of whichever
religion, or people are committing atrocities
in the name of all of those religions, you—you
have to come to the place where you understand
what your faith truly is.
And most times when you read different accounts...I
read different accounts in the Bible, I'm
not just looking at, um, "eye for an eye."
You have to rationalize the meaning of "eye
for an eye" into this world.
And—and one old lady said, "If you practice
eye-for-an-eye now, we're going to have a
group of damned blind people all over the
world."
[laughter] So you have to think about that,
but for me one thing that I picked from the
life of Jesus was compassion.
And there is no way that you can live and
interact with people and don't feel a sense
of compassion when something has gone wrong
or something is going wrong.
So, over time, different things led me.
I had been writing a little book for so long
and I paused on that book.
But my desire is to publish that book and
just give it out for free.
It's a tiny book that I've titled "Giving."
And in that book, it will be... if you read
it you'll get to understand how my faith grew
so strong.
Because in my life's journey, it hasn't been
just Christians that have reached out to me.
It hasn't been just Muslims.
It's been people of different faiths and they
are reading different things and just trying
to make sense of this world that we all know
that God...or believe that a God created.
If he created this world, how did he intend
for us to live?
How can you say I'm a person of faith and
you see a child suffering and not offer that
person food?
How can you be a person of faith and see a
young girl with so much potential and you
have the resources to send her to school,
and turn a blind eye?
So you have all of those things in play.
But again, I tell people my life journey has
been one that I track.
I'll give you a quick story.
My kids and I had been very, very poor, um,
for a long time.
And then my sister moved back to Monrovia
from exile, and we lived in a tiny—in a
tiny apartment.
I think the entire apartment was the size
of this stage.
And I had four kids.
She had one daughter, then I had a brother
I took, and a niece came to live.
So in this space...then a girl was thrown
out, we took her in to help her finish high
school.
Every morning we would make food, breakfast
and put it on the porch, and the kids in the
neighborhood would cross over and come to
eat.
And I would say, "Make way for others to come
and eat."
And my sister would glare at me and say, "You
are so going to call armed robbers in this
house tonight," because it was a rough neighborhood.
And one of the days I took...
I just sat and looked even though we were
poor, there were poor people, people poorer
than we were.
And so all of these old pairs of shoes under
the bed, and it was getting close to Christmas
and I said to her, "Mommy, Let's give these
shoes out to the kids in the neighborhood."
So we took everything out and children came,
and not a single pair left over.
My niece had made a list...we had made a list,
but I had I think less than a hundred dollars
for that Christmas.
And that money would not deal with anything.
The kids were upset because it's two days
'til Christmas and mama can't seem to be filling
this list.
I had this friend who was a Catholic priest
who used to just come and sit in my house,
to laugh, he said.
The kids were just crazy because every night
we did a thing called peacebuilding.
And every night my son Arthur who is 16 now
was the only culprit, apologizing to everyone,
"I'm very sorry.
I'm very sorry."
So if you came to my house for 30 days Arthur
was the one apologizing.
So this man used to come and just sit sometimes
and pray with us.
He had gone to England and he came that evening
at 12 midnight.
A Catholic priest knocking at the window of
a single woman at 12 midnight?
Of course, I was shocked! [laughter] And I
was like, "What do you want?" and he said,
"Just open your door."
"No, no, no, no, why...you should be in London."
He said, "Just open the door.
It's a long story.
I'm tired.
My flight came in late.
I want..."
So he...when I opened the front door, he put
two huge suitcases in my living room.
And then he said, "I'm too sleepy.
We'll talk about it tomorrow.
I'll come in."
So the kids woke up and said, "What's in the
suitcase?" the next morning.
I said, "Well, brother David brought these—these
two suitcases."
By 12 he came.
And then he said when he was leaving England,
there was this woman who came running to the
priest's house and said, "You are going to
Africa.
It's Christmas.
I have these two suitcases.
Go and give it to any single mother."
He brought those suitcases and said...he used
to call me "Leymuth" that's how they call
me in the community that's my rough gangster
name.
[laughter] So he-he-he brought these...so
he said, "So I brought these two suitcases."
We sat down and opened up those suitcases.
And everything we had on our list was in those
suitcases, including shoes for the kids and
clothes for the kids.
And I turned and looked at my sister, and
she looked back at me.
When you've lived a life of lack, and when
God has stepped in mysteriously on many occasions
— and that's just one — and provided in
such an awesome way, sometimes you don't need
the Bible to give you an understanding of
who God is.
[applause] I want to stay with that whole
issue of faith just for a little bit longer.
When you started working, uh, on the issue
that concerned...with organizing women to
stand up against Charles Taylor...who was
the first...how did it happen that the Muslim,
um, your Muslim associate, the lead woman
from that group, crossed that boundary or
you crossed it because that wasn't the case
at the time?
Well, when...first of all the Christian Women's
Peace Initiative and...I went to bed.
I used to live with my computer, my kids were
in exile so I lived in this house all by myself
and uh...no I did not go on the computer at
that time, I take that back.
But I had a notebook that I wrote everything
in.
And I remember that night laying next to the
window and having this notebook.
And I woke up shivering.
But, in that dream, real dream, "Gather the
women to pray for peace."
The next morning — my boss was a pastor
— and I went to him and said, BB, I had
this dream."
And Vaiba, who's been here, was also one of
my bosses then.
And this person was saying to me, "Gather
the women."
So, "Reverend," --that's how we called our
boss -- "since you are a pastor, call the
women of the church and give them this dream."
And he looked at me and said, "Leymah, the
dream bearer is always the carrier of the
dream."
I said, "No, no, no, no, no, no Reverend.
I am in a relationship and I'm not married
to the man.
Oh, am I fornicating!
No, Jesus could not be talking to me."
[laughter] And then he said, "No."
And so we started the whole Christian Women's
Peace Initiative.
And the first time we went to meet a delegation
of the World Council of Churches, Asatu was
the Mus—only Muslim woman who stood up and
say she was going to take it back to her Muslim
sisters.
She went and threw the idea at them.
And the first question they asked was, "Who
organized the Christian women?"
And she said, "Leymah."
So technically they baptized me a Muslim to
come and organize the Muslim women.
We started working with them because the first
thing we needed to know what time they were...all
of those things.
But what happened, very interesting in all
of this faith conversation most times when
I'm having interfaith dialogue with people
I ask, "In this work that we did, who do you
think were the most problematic group?"
And because of the impression of the-the-the-the-the,
um, myth of Muslim fun--fundamentalism, everyone
will say instantly, "The Muslim women were
the most difficult."
No.
All those Christian women would come with
scripture references every morning [laughter]
on reasons why we should not interact with
the Muslim women.
Sometimes it got so bad that we had to take
these women aside and really just talk to
them to apologize.
And so it got to the place where one group
of Christian women actually left us because
they felt we were not fulfilling the work
of God.
But the Muslim women were the most easy to
deal with than the Christian women.
Strangely.
This... that brings up another question about...when
you think about standing up, I mean you did
it there, you do it now, you help women around
the world.
You're really interested in this transformation
of conflict.
Do you think about going alone first to see
what needs to be done, or do you begin organizing
coalitions?
Because this is about the coalitions coming
together like these groups first.
I mean because they're challenging.
One seems like it's going to take a lot more
time, one seems like you're testing the waters.
What...when you think about going out, what
do you do first?
I think the first thing to do is identify
not one but several thematic concerns in different
communities.
Where people miss the mark is to think that
once you see women you mobilize.
That's not it.
Or once you see people you mobilize.
People have to feel connected to something.
So you look into...say this community...and
maybe rape, um...domestic violence - like
wife beating, um...wayward children are the
key issues.
And you have to really go around and kind
of test the waters with...if you're trying
to mobilize parents, to see which is the top
of the list.
And then you use that as your rallying call.
So when you go into conflict areas you want
to really start by finding something...even
though...for example, in the Congo DRC, when
we went there two, three years ago, two-and-a-half
years ago, I knew we still had a lot of work
to do.
There was no way that what happened in Liberia
would happen in Congo any time soon.
Why?
Because everyone sees the conflict from the
lens of their ethnic group or their political
ideology or, um, some leader.
They haven't seen it from the standpoint of,
"Yes, I'm from this party and I'm from this
ethnic group, but rape is an issue and it's
affecting us as women."
We went to Bukavu and we sat in that place,
had a very beautiful meeting where the women
had all of the answers.
And then we said, "OK, if we are to form a
coalition, we need to get one person who will
become the face of this movement.
The person would be the voice, and when they're
not around no one can speak, because then
the message is simple, concise and clear.
No one is giving, um, mixed messages."
The meeting broke down there.
In the Ivory Coast in 2004 before their war
got hot we went to a meeting, same thing.
They spoke the same language.
When it came time to fin—find the leader,
the meeting broke down — the reason being,
people still see that leadership within that
women's group from the perspective of the
political group, the ethnic group or the rebel
faction that they support.
And that's a really interesting point because
it—it creates a vision of how you would
have to get people to buy in to the whole
idea of these coalitions that you want to
create.
On the other hand, certainly you're going
to have to find the leaders who are willing,
who are acceptable beyond that point.
Well—well, one of the things that we didn't
talk about it in "Pray the Devil Back to Hell"
but which I think was a very important part
of the work that we did in Liberia, was when
we started something called the Peace Outreach
Project.
It was something called... we used to call
it the POP.
We trained 20 women from the Christian and
Muslim groups, and those 20 women sat down
and said, "We want to do something collectively."
After we had formed the Christian and Muslim
women.
And the first thing they said they wanted
to tackle was HIV and AIDS.
In two weeks the problem with the war started.
April 2nd actually would be 10 years when
we started the mass action.
So when we—we—we—we decided, "OK, let's
work on the war issue."
But the POP was something that they said,
"We want to be able to go out and tell local
women that they too have a stake in the peace
process."
So the Peace Outreach Project was predominantly
a time of awareness and mobilization, a rallying
call.
We did that for nine months.
After nine months we called the group back
to evaluate the work that we had done.
And we realized that there were issues that
were coming up that was very unhealthy for
the group that we are trying to build—Muslim/Christian
women's rela—uh, relationships.
So we—we did something—a consultation
that was paid for by Catholic Relief Services.
The first thing we brought the Christian women
in the room.
And we were looking at peace and nonviolence
from the perspective of the Bible, something
that they were quite familiar with, very comfortable
with.
And we talk about...because most times when
you talk to the Christian women, they would
be like, "Oh, my religion tells me to pray,
so I'm not supposed to be out there.
I'm not supposed to be on the forefront of
protests.
I'm just supposed to pray."
So then we went back to the Bible, sat down
and studied women in the Bible.
And we gave them Deborah, we gave them Esther,
we gave them all of those powerful women and
said, "Did they just pray?
No.
Did they take action?
Yes.
So can you be a Deborah for your country?
Of course!" [laughter] So those were the first
things we did.
Then we went into the Quran and into all of
the different readings that were Islam that
we could find.
The next day we brought the Muslim women.
Both two things we did to demystify all of
the myths and negative perceptions and positives,
stereotypes they had, was to do something
with the Christian women on the day.
What is it that you like about the Muslim
women?
And they made their long list.
What is it that you do not like about them?
What do you admire about Islam?
They made their long list, kept it, next day
worked with the Muslim women.
The third day we brought both groups together
and the room was divided by religion.
Every group was...what was amazing was that
two women drove in the same car, one a Christian,
one a Muslim.
As soon as they enter that room everyone was
across the table.
So we—we started by asking them to do the
gallery walk.
Christian women one side Muslim women...and
you could just hear it, "What!
Did they say this about us as Christians?
What?
Did they say this?"
"Oh, that is so nice."
[laughter] "Oh, oh, no but is a lie.
We are not like this."
"Oh that is so nice."
"Well that's not true.
Oh..." and then after a while we said we don't
want to talk about it.
We brought two old ladies who had been friends
for over 60-something years.
One a Christian, one a Muslim.
That was the turning point for us.
Because one of the women...the Muslim woman
was as talkative as I am.
[laughter] And the Christian woman was so
quiet and reserved.
It was a total contrast from what those women...the
perception that they held.
And then this Muslim woman, in her talking
about their friendship said, "My friend here's
husband used to abuse her.
And I took money and took her to the courts
and she divorced him."
Of course the Christian women almost fainted.
[laughter] A Muslim taking a Christian woman
to divorce her husband?
"And I made sure she got away with all of
the property."
But afterward [laughter] someone asked, "How
has your religion influenced your friendship?"
And those two old ladies had a blank look
on their faces.
"What are you talking about?"
And then this Muslim woman, who's deceased
now, turned and said, "Marta, when you look
at me do you see a Muslim?"
And the Christian woman said, "No, I see a
sister, a woman with many children, same problems
that I have, unfortunately, cheating husbands."
And they just went on and on and on.
And they said faith has never ever played
a role.
Those two women in their communities, because
of the intensity of their friendship, were
called witches by community members.
They suffered the worst together, but nothing
ever took their friendship away.
So that became the rallying call.
So when you hear in the movie, "Does the bullet
know a Christian from a Muslim?
Can a bullet pick and choose?"
Cause those women said...the two old ladies
said, "Go in the bathroom, take off your clothes,
one Muslim woman, one Christian woman.
And look at each other and see whether you
see a Muslim on your bodies or you see a Christian
written on your bodies."
So when you're trying to mobilize, it's so
important that you spend time.
Today, because of the horrific kind of violence
that we see in communities, people expect
that movements will just wake up.
It needs to be nurtured like you're building
a garden.
Take trash out, all of the weeds and all of
the different things and that's what we did
with those women for over...almost two years
before we launched the mass action.
Very impressive.
[applause] I've—I am checking the time...I—I
have one more question I really want to ask
because I've been watching and looking at
a number of... statements that you've made
in recent times and I've seen you take to
the podium to confront leaders of Africa and
the Western world the northern communities.
Um, speak about their role in the continuing
conflicts.
I mean, to take them on and say what role
they're playing.
And I think that—that those moments when
I see you doing that I'm wondering...
I'm thinking about your work with your women,
companionship, etc.
But what gives you this power?
What are you really saying to these people
who are you believe continuing the conflicts
at some level—who are heads of state, etc.
And does anybody ever listen to you?
Does anybody respond when you—when you speak
out?
Well, when you don't get invited to some country
high-level meeting, [laughter] you take it
that they heard.
You know, and it's upsetting to them.
But the point, um, Dee, is that in this work
that we do we should not be afraid of anyone.
There shouldn't be an office that we cannot
touch.
There shouldn't be an individual that we cannot
face.
And most times when I sit and form my opinion
and do my research and do my analysis about
certain things, the first thing that comes
to mind is that people expect that you be
quiet because you're a girl.
You know, how dare you talk to those male
leaders!
But when Archbishop Tutu says, "I cannot share
a stage with Tony Blair because he's a war
criminal," he's applauded and I respect him
for that.
You know?
And I think that is what should be.
We should be able to say...because Dee, who
do we represent?
Who is your constituent?
Who do I represent?
A vast majority of those women that I say
I speak for may never make it to San Diego.
And if I'm afraid and ashamed to speak about
their issues, I've failed them and I've failed
them miserably.
You know they—they had the misfortune of
putting me on a high-level task force on reproductive
health and rights beyond 2015.
And I asked someone, "Do you really think
you want me on this task force?"
[laughter] Because it's not going to be about
politics.
Like I said this morning, it's not going to
be about statistics.
It's going to be about individuals.
So how do you live in a country where you
can...women die in the hundreds from maternal-related
issues?
They're going to give birth and they're dying.
And then you have the children of some of
the leaders riding the best cars.
And it's simple things like an ultrasound
machine you can't find in some of the health
centers.
And I'll say...you know, I'll say it doesn't
take a lot.
And so when you—you—you say to yourself...most
times I tell myself, if Dr. King was going
to be afraid, there would be no civil rights
movement in this country.
And I don't think, I don't think it's fair
for any of us who God has given a space to
dominate, to be afraid to speak our minds
— especially if it has to do with people
who cannot speak for themselves.
[applause] I'm going to ask one final question.
In the meantime why don't people head over
to the mikes so we can hear your questions.
And that's because I'm sure that we have students
here and I know that a number of people, um,
have an interest in media and that you've
been interviewed by people in media who are
the alternative news media and, um, found
them somewhat responsive, I think.
And I think the role of media, as we've talked
about earlier today and in the past, is profound
and it's essential that we have responsible
media.
So when you go on someone's show like Jon
Stewart or Stephen Colbert, um, what's the
sense...I mean, are they in their own way
trying to get the real word out there?
Are they...um...
[Gbowee]: I think...
I—I will speak for both Colbert and Jon
Stewart and I will not speak about some of
the other people that interviewed me.
[Aker]: I'll only ask you about those two.
[laughter] [Gbowee]: But those two, especially
Jon Stewart, came into the green room, sat
with me for almost 30 minutes.
And it wasn't like calming my nerves; because
look at me I didn't need him to calm my nerves.
[laughter] But it was like genuinely engaging:
"I've read your book.
I have kids.
I'm concerned about the state of the world."
And he came to me with a lot of respect.
There was not this white male supremacy thing.
It was like two equals having a conversation:
You have something to say, I'm interested
in listening to it.
And I—I've been to many places and it's
not just for North America.
Even in Africa you get the vibe when people
are not interested and they just see you as...okay
this is going to be a...I—I tell my kids
with this prize I'm not an ornament.
You know because it's easy for..."oh, we got
this Nobel Laureate to come to this event.
And this Nobel Laureate to come to that event."
No.
I will be an ornament when I'm 70.
[laughter] [Aker]: Oh shoot.
[Gbowee]: At 41 there is work to be done and
you can't afford to but...you...I mean...you...
sometimes you get the sense and with Jon I
really got the sense that first things first,
he had read my book.
It speaks volumes about someone interviewing
you who has read, but beyond reading has gone
and done different research.
And—and talk about do...I've done this,
I've done that, I've done the other.
So and—and...when we had that conversation,
the people in that audience, if they had never
thought about civil wars or women's rights
issues, it brought it to them because he drove
it home.
And we, you know, at one point during the
interview, he said, "Wow, you're being interviewed
by the most popular—one of the most popular
journalists in America."
And I said, "Well, you...we're in good company
because you are interviewing the most popular
African woman."
[laughter and applause] Yeah, I couldn't resist
asking the question because I know it's hard
when we talk about media to feel that we're
getting an honest, uh, sense of...from media
about what's going on in the world and—and
what they have to do.
And I think that we really need to take it
more into those kinds of spaces if we want
the world to take women's issues seriously,
because it...those people have followings.
They have people who want to hear them.
They're like little gods to people.
So if some of them stand up and say, "Women's
rights is the in thing," some people will
be listening, others who have never stopped
to think about it.
So when you talk about breaking new ground
and going into different spaces and new places,
I think those are the kinds of people that
we need to engage with.
Find the good men in the media because for
too long and especially for me...one of the
things I constantly say to myself as I go
to be interviewed or go to some part of the
world, there's so much misconception about
the African woman — saggy breasts, begging
bowl, many children hanging on them.
You know, and sometimes I tell people, that
even if... in Africa a woman has been raped,
the one question you need to ask yourself
, "How is she still caring for 10, 20 children?
How is she still caring even after that horrifying
rape, how is she still standing up with her
shoulders high and providing for her family?"
You need to move beyond the act of the rape
and look deep into that strength.
The strength that is coming out.
So most times there...one thing that I would
never ever hope to do is to come out here
because again, I'm not representing myself.
I'm representing a lot of those women in communities
who you cannot mess with.
You know, I was...we went...when the Nobel
women came, we took them to a group of women
in Totota.
The women, when they were introducing themselves
to the Nobel women, and I just sat there smiling,
because these were women I met decades ago
who could not even find their voices.
And this woman stands and says, "I have my
lieutenants.
Where are my lieutenants?"
And these women stand up.
And these are the people who community people
would come to and say, "My daughter got raped
and the culprit lives in that house."
Those women walk to that house, arrest the
man, and take him to the police station.
You dare not resist arrest.
[laughter and applause] So if you have these
things happen in community, how do you come
off portraying those women you represent as
weak?
As...and then you find...we have a whole new
generation of young women who have formed
their—their voices also, so they are nothing
like weak.
And previously when things used to happen,
they would be so shy about talking about it.
But we've come...seriously come to the place
where African women are now saying, "If you
rape me, I have nothing to be ashamed of.
You should be ashamed of yourself!"
You know, so...we need to constantly portray
that.
Even in this country I constant...
I will alw...I always say, "Women, you have
so much: the platform, the resources."
Um, someone said to me, "You know there was
this thing going and we—I won a million
dollars for my organization."
I said, "Gosh.
Give me one million dollars [laughter] and
I know what I will do with it!"
So much resources and then sometimes when
you hear some of the things going on you ask
yourself, "These women are strong, they're
smart, they're intelligent, but what happened
to their legs?
Why can't they stand up?"
Because you see there is so much that you
have to offer us in Africa.
You...people mirror what happens in this part
of the world.
If—if women's rights is not respected here,
and our leaders are wining and dining with
your leaders, they go back and say, "Even
in the... even in the U.S. is not working
there.
Why should we give it to you here?"
Okay, let me shut up, Dee. [laughter and applause]
No, here's a microphone, there's an empty
microphone for Leymah.
[Female voice from off stage] I want to ask
you about the horrific violence, not only
in Liberia, but in so many places in Africa.
Eastern Congo you talked about and other places.
[clears throat] At the beginning you talked
about this wonderful spirit in Africa of sharing,
of taking care of each other.
I think you say "ubuntu."
Is that right?
And [clears throat] I wonder how we restore
that.
What—what were the dark forces that changed
things, that brought this about, and how do
we reverse it?
You know I don't think the spirit of togetherness
and oneness ever left Africa, or else people
like us wouldn't be on the continent still.
The spirit is still there.
What we've seen happen to our world is something
that we cannot explain.
When people...I—I—I tell most of the young
men who fought in the war that you are a victim
of, um, trying to live in an urban world,
not fitting, and trying to live in your rural
community and not fitting there anymore.
So mod—modern—modernity or whatever we
want to call it, but it's—it's a sad...
I—I cannot pinpoint what has happened to
the spirit in our communities.
What I can say to you is that in some parts
of the community those spirits are still there.
It's the spirit that will cause women to rally
around each other.
It's that same spirit that will get some men
to come around.
And most times when I speak to a community
of African men, I say to them the reason why
you all are now demonized is because a lot
of you good men have stepped in the back,
and the evil ones have taken over your space.
And the evil men, the men who perpetrate evil,
are not many.
The ones who are the good ones, they're very
many, but somehow they've lost their spines
and they're not doing enough to protect those
women.
I don't understand what is happening.
But when I look at my own dad, who as we grew
up, no woman cried from her husband's house
that he did not walk to and pull that man
out and say, "If you want to fight someone,
let's fight."
But today you see men, you see boys really
most times they just don't want to get involved.
And so how do we get them to be like the women
again, you know, bring back that spirit of
community?
But I also think a lot of the violence that
they too have seen has affected them in ways
that we are not talking about.
And because...I mean the good men now, the
handful of the evil ones have affected them
in ways that... there's something about their
pride that has been wounded.
If you could not protect your wife from rape,
who are you in this time of peace to stand
up and say you want to be an advocate for
rape?
And I think it's up to us women and those
of the other men who are doing this work to
really now start saying what happened happened,
and it's time for us to take back our communities.
Yeah.
[A different female voice from offstage] Thanks
so much for sharing your stories and as I've
been hearing them, um, I've just been thinking
a lot about the grassroots movements and the
organizing efforts.
And wondering in your... because not everyone
is Leymah Gbowee.
Not everybody is going to end up with a Nobel
Prize.
So, who are your teammates?
Who are the people who have walked with you
in this journey?
And what kind of group do you like to surround
yourself with to make a movement sustainable
and possible and powerful?
Crazy women.
[laughter] Risk-takers.
People who are not concerned about anything,
who will do anything, who are not concerned
about, "What do I stand to gain from this?"
One of the things that, um, I say to people
when we did this work and constantly I never
claim the glory, to say I—I did this by
myself.
It was group of women.
Every time that I try to tell people, "This
one is more powerful than I am; all I did
was to be the talkative one in the group."
But, the...some of the women...the—the work
that we've done has been a work of sacrifice.
And those are the people that you want to...if
you're building a movement, build a movement
around.
You don't want to build your movement around
those who are thinking, "Wow, how much money
are we going to get out of this?"
When we started the—the protests, and when
we did all of the work that we had done in
the past, I tell people I could not keep a
dime in my handbag.
Because it wasn't just building a movement,
it was building a community of women.
We were building sisterhood to the point that
we all knew each other's problems.
Vaiba, who came here to do the Women PeaceMakers
Program, lost her husband in 2006.
And that afternoon when he got really sick,
they called me.
I went and saw him taking his last breath.
And they asked the women, they took us and
we went so I had to leave with her.
When he died, because he was a Muslim, his
family came and immediately said, "You killed
him.
So you have to explain to us how he died."
One phone call, 25 women were in that house.
The men said, "We changed our mind.
You didn't do anything to him.
[laughter] He died a natural death."
But I saw us sleep in that tiny house, the
next morning trek to the gravesite, stayed
with her for two weeks.
When they finally were doing their official
mourning, we did the women's mourning, which
is not common in the Muslim faith.
We did everything together.
And that was what we did from one community
to the other.
Sometimes as someone gave birth we were all
there.
So it wasn't just about peace.
It was reaffirming ourselves as women, telling
people that we've got your back.
The personal is political.
There is no way any of us can say, "I'm a
peace activist and I'm doing such a great
job," but the people you work with you don't
interact or engage with them in that way.
My sisters tell me if I live in Africa I'm
not going to be rich.
And I don't think I will be rich, because
whatever you own has to be shared.
So the kind of people that you'll find me
hanging out with would be those women who
when one person cries everyone will appear.
And when they come together, even when you're
crying, they will do something to wipe that
tears away from your eyes.
When my sister died in 2006, by the time I
landed with the body at the airport, the WIPNET
women were lined up.
Some of them were so drunk they didn't know
what they were doing there.
[laughter] But that evening when my parents
were grieving, I remember my dad was so sad.
Those women decided to put up a fashion show
for him.
[laughter] And I just saw him looking like,
"What kind of trouble is this, Leymah?
Get these women out of this house."
And I said, "No," and you know, just... afterwards
you would not hear crying in that house.
That was the spirit.
And that is the spirit of any movement that
will survive.
[applause] I'll take two more—you and one
more, and then I saw a little pretty girl
come up there.
Oh sorry, go ahead go ahead oh. [off screen—nervous
male laugh] Standing here as a man.
[nervous male laugh] And we're happy you're
here.
[off screen] Thank you.
I'm happy um to be here and I want to thank
you madam for your courage.
You invoked Rev. Martin Luther King, who we
may agree was a prophet and a courageous one.
Who was also a man who we understand that
he had some the failings that all men and
women have.
But he stood up.
And my question is: we're all sitting here
listening to you and feeling very good about
what you're saying.
It's—it's encouraging to sit here.
Would you encourage us to stand up and participate
in civil disobedience in this country now?
And in what way would you encourage us to
do that?
And that's my question.
Thank you.
I...when the Newtown shooting took place,
um, the Africa columnist for Daily Beast...
I stayed in my room and sent a thing—a rallying
call to the mothers of America, um, to rise
up against gun violence in this country.
Um, I like the way...the trend the debate
is taking, but I think there is a need for,
um, and this is my naïve African perspective,
but I think there's a need for more grassroots
organizing around the whole issue of gun violence
in this country because after Newtown, what
has happened to that conversation is that
it has gotten very political.
So it's a Joe Biden issue.
But when the shooters go on the rampage, it's
not a Joe Biden's...even though he feels it
and I'm not saying your leaders are not compassionate.
But the people who feel it the most are the
community people.
And I think when you talk about civil disobedience
or—or—or protests against certain things,
I think those are the kind of things that
people need to really start standing up to.
But if a community feels passionate about
something, and that's how we started the conversation,
a thematic concern, an issue of concern, and
if the community feels like they are not being
heard about that particular issue, I don't
think anyone can...as long as you are not
going to be throwing stones and throwing petrol
bombs at people.
I think it's important for people to be able
to express themselves, express the way they
feel about a particular thing.
I am all for protests, peaceful protests,
nonviolent, um, protests and nonviolent engagement
on issues that are dissatisfactory to a...for
a group of people.
So I think there are many things in this country
that women, men, boys and girls can decide
we're going to stand up to.
Um, when we were in Chicago a few days ago,
one of the things that I told them there because
of course, Hafeeza, would make me—Hafeeza,
my assistant there, read all of these briefing
books—about Dee what year she was born,
which school she went to, the dean and everyone
else, but in that briefing book there was
all of these statistics and different things
about Chicago and the strategies of the police.
And when we met with the mayor that's what
he constantly talked about: "Oh, my police
chief is doing well."
And then I said to him, "Sir, with all due
respect, and I'm sure you are doing a great
job, this is not just a police issue.
It is a community issue.
You should elicit the support of, uh, elicit
the support of religious leaders, schoolteachers,
parents, community people.
Organize a different group of people so that
this issue starts from the...is—is tackled
from the grassroots to the top level.
So everyone has a role to play in making communities
straight.
My theory: the world is upside down.
We need many hands to turn it upright.
And many strategies.
One last question.
[Young girl's voice off screen] Um, I know
what you went through because my parents ran
away from Somalia when I was a young kid.
And I came with the IRC Peacemakers and I
was wondering, how did you overcame all this?
It—it's something that never goes away.
You know, you see all of this, sometimes you
see all of this strength and you see all of
this um...everything you see, it's easy to
have a flashback.
It's easy to walk into a space and just black
out.
It's easy to cry.
It's easy to be upset and angry.
And because you have all of these emotions
happening every time, what is not easy is
for you to keep going.
And for me that's where I find myself.
Um, some days I have this tough thing going
on about me, trying to be the girl, but inside
I'm like Jell-O. You know, it—it's so much
happening.
And you—you're just so emotional about things
you see happen.
And once you've gone through it, my dear,
it—it's—it's internal.
And it is not—it's not about where you come
from anymore.
So when I hear the stories of women in Mali,
it's my story.
When I hear the stories of women in Sudan,
When I hear the stories of women even here
in the U.S., who...single mothers who have
gone through many different things, refugee
women, it's my story.
So trust me.
It never goes away.
And one of the things I tell young people,
old people, there is no way we can do this
work that we're doing if we don't believe
there's a high—higher power responsible
for some of the things happening.
Now, I'm not saying be a good Christian, be
a good Muslim, be a Judist—uh, a Jewish,
uh, be a Hindu.
What I'm saying is you have to have a kind
of faith to be able to negotiate this world
if you're a peacebuilder or peace activist
or a change agent, because you'll see so many
things that will make you angry.
I— [whistle sound] I always ask this question,
"What similar traits does Hitler and Martin
Luther King have?
Dee?
Some of the traits?
Yes, one characteristics that Hitler and King
has or share or...
Desmond Tutu and Charles Taylor?"
[Gbowee]:Trait.
[Aker]: Traits?
[laughs] [Gbowee]: One characteristics or
traits or whatever or one—one thing they
share.
And the mayor of Chicago says, "Well, besides
humanity I don't see anything they share."
I said, "Well, anger."
Hitler was an angry man.
Dr. King was angry.
Mandela was angry.
Charles Taylor was angry.
I've been angry.
Other women are angry.
What distinguish us from the other is how
we put...where we put our anger.
So, pardon me.
I have this thing that I say, I go like this.
Fluid.
Has no shape or size.
So this is the peace container and this is
the war container.
And anger is not in any of this here.
And you can decide, "OK, I'm really angry
right now.
But I'm going to pour my anger into the peace
container."
And what you see is someone who is building
peace and doing something positive with their
anger.
Anger is what keeps me going.
Anger is something that...it's like the fuel
that I need to do something.
But I never ever think that I'm going to pour
my anger into a violent container.
And so when you do—when you—when you say,
"Does it ever go away?
No, no mama, it never goes away.
All you have to do is, where do I pour my
anger?
Where do I pour all of those emotions so that
will make sense to the world, and that will
leave a—that will leave a legacy?
And most times when you've gone through war,
you've through a situation the question you
need to ask yourself is, "Do I want to put
this in this violent container and end up
in the Hague or end up a villain?
Or do I want to put it in this peace container
and end up leaving a perfect legacy, like
someone like King or Mandela or Tutu or Mother
Theresa?"
Because all of these people like all of the
people we consider villains had one common
thing, and that thing was anger.
Tonight as you to go home, think about it,
teach your children that anger is neither
good nor bad, but how you pour your anger
is what your life story end will be.
Thank you all very much.
[applause]